now it just amazes me how many people
especially in the medical profession
just treat constipation as a symptom
they do not look at the whole picture
they might just tell you it's just a
lack of fiber
just take more fiber metamucil whatever
and
fiber will stimulate the colon which
will help you evacuate and it's
hydrating so just take some fiber
that's it but constipation is the effect
of
incomplete digestion anywhere in your
digestive tract
i mean it could be a lack of stomach
acid because
stomach acid helps you break down
protein if you're not breaking down
protein
that can end up as undigested protein
then you have the pancreas
which produces all these enzymes and
enzymes
really work in the small intestine you
have like 20 feet of
of tubing called the small intestine
which by the way your small intestine
the little villi
actually make enzymes and also the
pancreas releases enzymes
in the small intestine and that's where
90 of all your digestion
occurs and so that doesn't occur
correctly
guess what undigested food both
undigested carbohydrates undigested fats
undigested protein and it ends up as a
constipation situation then you have the
liver that makes
bile salts and it's stored by the
gallbladder and that's released into the
small intestine
and bile salts are the detergent that
helps break down
fat to a certain level where the enzymes
in the pancreas can then take over
and fully digest the fats
but the thing about bile is bile
lubricates the colon
bile hydrates the colon
and so if you're deficient in bile you
could very easily get constipation
now the problem with getting too much
bile as you end up with diarrhea
so you just need just the right amount
not too much not too little
so after all this food is digested from
the acid from the enzymes from the bile
it finally ends up into the large
intestine called the colon
this is where your friendly microbes
both friendly bacteria and friendly
yeast take over
and they start to finalize this
digestive process
they will take things that you can't
digest like fiber
and break those down they also help
reabsorb the water as well
and so if you have constipation it could
be
that you need more stomach acid you need
bile salts
you need enzymes or you need a good
probiotic
16 of americans have constipation
and 30 of americans over 60 have
constipation so it's a big deal
and i really want you to take a look at
the whole digestive process if you
personally have constipation rather than
just
one thing like adding more fiber
and so you can get a clue on the cause
of constipation and what you need to do
based on
when it started so let's say you started
after an antibiotic
well guess what you need probiotics and
by the way anytime you're on an
antibiotic
you should automatically take probiotics
at the same time don't wait till you're
done
take it at the same time you take
antibiotics
now let's say for example you develop
constipation when you took an
antacid well then just put back the acid
betaine hydrochloride or let's say you
started taking medications
that have a side effect of constipation
well get with your doctor and find some
alternative that doesn't have a side
effect of constipation
or let's say you had a history of eating
a lot of cooked foods
a lot of processed foods and no raw
foods
that have enzymes well then start eating
raw foods like raw vegetables
or let's say there wasn't an actual time
that it started
but you don't like vegetables you don't
consume a lot of vegetables an average
american consumes like a cup and a half
of
vegetables well guess what we need that
fiber for
our microbes to actually live off of
we also need the potassium and magnesium
in those vegetables to help
the pumping action of your colon
in fact when you add more potassium
magnesium
that does help the bowels work correctly
and a lot of times people instead of
consuming vegetables
they might take epsom salts right which
creates a laxative effect
and then they get diarrhea also too many
high carbohydrates
can interfere with the nervous system
that
controls this whole process
it's called the enteric part of the
autonomic nervous system
so if that's the case you need something
called benfotamine
which is a type of b vitamin that
actually will help
support that issue also frequent eating
it's the cramming of all this food
down this pipe never letting the body
properly digest and go through its cycle
it takes 36 hours
for food to be completely processed
through your entire
digestive tract so if we're eating
so frequently all the time we never get
a chance for your system to really clean
out
another point is stress stress activates
the fly to fight mechanism which
inhibits
the nervous system that controls the
digestion which is called the
parasympathetic nervous system
so many many times you don't need to
change the diet
you just need to fully relax you need to
improve the parasympathetic nervous
system and i put a link down below
how you should do that reducing your
stress
greatly improves your digestion and so a
couple other tips
fermented foods are good increasing your
veggies increasing more fat
which will stimulate bile production
because if you're on a low fat diet that
can be a reason why you don't have
enough bile
and if you're in the bile things dry up
and you get constipation
also lowering your carbs already
mentioned that and then doing
intermittent fasting is very very
important all right thanks for watching
hey before you go real quick i have a
course
entitled how to bulletproof your immune
system
it's a free course i want you to take it
and here's why
here's you here is your
environment everyone
is focused on this over here avoiding
your environment but what about here
what about strengthening
your immune system that's what's missing
this course will show you
how to bulletproof yourself and so you
can tolerate and resist your environment
much better
by strengthening your own immune system
i put a link down in the description
right down below
check it out and get signed up today